[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal préparé par la rédaction de tv
78 tout de suite les titres de ce
mercredi 9 janvier une première étape au
départ de saint-germain-en-laye la
seconde depuis la commune des bréviaires
le tracé du paris-nice 2019 a été
dévoilée ce matin au conseil
départemental des yvelines à versailles
pour la dixième année consécutive la
conso soleil s'élancera du département
elles sont lancées pour six semaines les
soldes d'hiver se déroulent jusqu'au 19
février les commerçants espère doper
leurs ventes les consommateurs trouver
de bonnes affaires et nous étions ce
matin au centre commercial vélizy 2 où
les 160 enseignes accueilli leurs
premiers clients
et puis la fonction n'avait pas été
occupée depuis plus de 50 ans le diocèse
de versailles va compter bientôt un
évêque auxiliaire le père bruno valentin
a été nommé par le pape françois son
ordination épiscopale est prévue le 20
janvier il est notre invité
autre invité sur ce plateau
l'association élan courtoise reydel toi
qui organise samedi à sa fête de noël
avant de développer ses titres carlos
ghosn reste en prison au moins jusqu'à
vendredi la demande de remise en liberté
du patron du groupe renault implantée
notamment à guyancourt a été rejetée par
le tribunal de tokyo le pdg est
incarcéré au japon depuis à 50 jours
accusé notamment de dissimulation de
revenus chez nissan entre 2010 et 2015
et pour la période 2015 2018
la présentation officielle du à
paris-nice s'est donc déroulée ce matin
à l'hôtel du département à versailles la
course au soleil partira le 10 mars
depuis saint germain en laye le
lendemain le peloton s'élancera de la
commune des bréviaires dans le sud des
yvelines les détails avec mélanie poquet
et michael et demi d'euros un mariage
qui dure depuis dix ans le paris-nice
partira une nouvelle fois depuis les
yvelines après chatou l'année dernière
saint germain en laye été retenue comme
ville départ de cette 67e édition et
coureurs repartiront le dimanche 10 mars
du parc du château pour une grande
boucle de 130 8 5 km à travers les
imminent passant notamment par touahri
montfort l'amaury ou encore poissy
pourquoi saint germain parce que saint
germain c'est prestigieux mais c'est
saint germain c'est le château parce que
saint germain il ya des perspectives
formidables aussi pour la transmission
de la télé
et parce qu'on avait été super bien
accueilli en 2013 lors d'un précédent
départ de paris nice à saint germain en
laye a pas que le paris saint-germain il
ya énormément de pratique sportive et
donc c'est important effectivement de
montrer que c'est une étape qui
populaire le vélo c'est très populaire
le lundi 11 mars à 12h35 le peloton
s'élancera des bréviaires pour une étape
de 173,5 kilomètres la petite commune de
1300 habitants située dans le sud des
yvelines deviendra la dix septième ville
du département à accueillir l'épreuve
c'est un événement historique à la fin
pour les bréviaires et pour moi
personnellement on va voir toutes les
écoles voisines qui va venir participer
avec des départs en vélo donc il ya
saint germain cité royale célèbre son
château et puis il ya de l'autre côté
des bréviaires la plus petite commune de
paris nice 2010 on en est ravi les
conditions s'y glisser ça sont des
grandes villes et des villes moyennes et
des petites communes les 1300 habitants
des bréviaires pourront notamment voir
en action 23 équipes cyclistes et
notamment des stars de la discipline
comme le colombien nairo quintana où les
français romain bardet ou arnaud démare
mais dans l'actualité également les
soldes d'hiver ont débuté aujourd'hui
pour six semaines moment fort pour les
clients est forcément pour les centres
commerciaux moins fréquentée depuis le
début du mouvement des gilet jaune
marylène yapi cheminots s'est rendu ce
matin à vélizy 2 au centre commercial
vélizy 2 ce mercredi matin les vitrines
des magasins annonce la couleur
les soldes d'hiver ont commencé des
réductions de 50% dès la première
démarque
après les fêtes les premiers jours de
soldes font partie des périodes les plus
importantes pour le centre et ses 160
enseignes
toute l'équipe est prête que ce soit
niveau de l'accueil des équipes de
nettoyage de maintenance tout le monde
est mobilisé en fait pour accueillir nos
clients dans les meilleures conditions
dans les rayons on fouille on cherche et
on fait bien attention à l'étiquette
pour trouver les meilleures affaires moi
je vois pas mal sur pantalon chacun sa
méthode
les plus raisonnables se fixe dans
budget je voudrais dépenses et ne pas
dépenser plus de 100 euros mais bon ça
dépend ce que je vais trouver et les
plus organisés viennent avec une idée
précise
je suis venu chercher un repérage que ma
femme avait fait le week end dernier
donc je fais des lui acheter une paire
de chaussures les premiers jours est le
plus important en terme d'affluence
alors il fallait être sur la ligne de
départ dès ce mercredi pour être certain
de trouver chaussure à son pied
ah oui exactement parce que pour des
chaussures après on ne trouve pas la
bonne pointure
rien que dans cette enseigne de
prêt-à-porter quarante mille articles
sont démarqués six semaines pour
liquider les stocks installer les
collections printemps été un invité m'a
rejoint en plateau monseigneur bruno
valentin bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous étiez jusqu'à lors le curé de
la paroisse de montigny le bretonneux
voisin jeudi jusqu alors qu'ils en
décembre vous avez été nommé par le pape
françois évêque auxiliaire de versailles
et votre ordination épiscopale est
prévue le 20 janvier en la cathédrale
saint-louis de versailles je précise que
vous avez 46 ans bientôt 47 47 pendant
comment vous avez accueilli cette
nouvelle avec de la surprise d'abord un
parce que comme vous venez de le dire
j'ai 46 ans qui fait de moi le plus
jeune évêque de france d'accord et puis
surtout parce que personne ne savait que
monseigneur aumônier évêque de
versailles avait demandé au pape un
auxiliaire depuis un certain temps
d'ailleurs
donc ne sachant pas que cette demande
était en cours je ne soupçonnais encore
moins que ce serait moi qui serais
désigné et un évêque auxiliaire à sur le
diocèse de versailles on n'en a pas vu
depuis 1966 à l'époque où le diocèse
étaient plus grand puisqu'il s'étendait
sur l'ensemble de la seine-et-oise
exactement à l'époque
la seine-et-oise faisait tout le tour de
paris on a découpé la seine et oise pour
faire les nouveaux départements d'île de
france et donc à cette époque le diocèse
avait deux auxiliaires mais depuis 66
ans n'avait plus donc c'est
effectivement c'est une fonction
nouvelle aujourd'hui pour les yvelines
un mot sur votre parcours vous avez été
ordonné prêtre en 2000 après des études
au séminaire de rome
un séminaire à rome c'est ça voilà
j'étais en ma formation de prêtres je
les fais tu as rome au souvenir français
et précédemment j'ai étudié la finance à
l'université de dauphine à paris
d'accord et vous avez été donc ensuite
vic et ratera purée à chatou et à
montigny voisins ça c'est depuis 2012
que vous n'êtes pas sur cette paroisse
différents coins des yvelines déjà dans
lesquels je suis passé depuis 20 ans
vous disiez c'était une totale surprise
vous n'aviez pas eu vent du tout de
cette de cette annonce non pas du tout
parce qu'en fait les évêques qui sont
choisis par le pape et la décision du
pape est transmise par son ambassadeur
en france et qui s'appelle le nonce
apostolique d'accord et donc on reçoit
un coup de téléphone de la nonciature
quête à paris on est prié de se
présenter dans des délais très brefs en
général ces dix jours pour le lendemain
et c'est là qu'on découvre les choses et
quand on ne fait pas acte de candidature
et c'est pas un poste à pourvoir auquel
on se propose
et quand on est nommé évêque auxiliaire
on est obligé d'accepter on ne peut pas
refuser cette cette fonction qui nous
est si on peut avoir des raisons
objectives de refuser mais il faut les
faire valoir et puis il faut surtout
recevoir ce genre de demande comme comme
comme un service qui nous est demandé
comment vous l'abordez 7 cette nouvelle
fonction vous disiez à nos confrères du
parisien avec une certaine crainte
c'était beau mot dans l'interview du
parisien oui presque
mais ce qu'on sait que le climat de
l'église en général et les evelyne n'y
échappe pas n'est pas facile aujourd'hui
donc c'est une responsabilité importante
pour essayer de en particulier redonner
de l'espérance redonner de la joie re
motiver les uns et les autres
c'est une charge lourde rider trebek
aujourd'hui vous parler d'un climat
particulier forcément un contexte on
parle de l'église catholique pas
forcément bien avec ses scandales de
pédophilie
le procès du cardinal philippe barbarin
qui se tient également en ce moment là
forcément dans un coin de sa tête ce
contexte difficile pour l'église quand
on accepte ce rôle de d'évêque
auxiliaire
bien sûr bien sûr parce que ce serait
tout à fait illusoire que d'imaginer
et que telle ou telle partie de france
n'est pas concernée par la question dans
les yvelines nous sommes concernés et
monseigneur oublié depuis 18 ans et très
vigilants à ce que ce genre d'histoire
quand elle se présente ça a pu être le
cas par le passé soit jugé dans une
parfaite bonne intelligence avec la
justice les évêques aujourd'hui c'est ce
que la justice nous rappelle à bon
escient
honte à être absolument irréprochable
ces questions et quelles sont les
missions du coût d'un évêque auxiliaire
l'évêque auxiliaire c'est l'adjoint en
fait c'est l'adjoint de l'évêque donc
c'est sa doublure c'est celui qui permet
au fonds à l'évêque d'être présent
partout en étant évêques pleinement
il a la possibilité du coup d'être
présent auprès des communautés aussi
bien qu auprès des autorités civiles de
manière complémentaire et donc sa
complète le rôle de l'évêque le rôle de
l'évêque tel et yellow si les mecs c'est
le responsable des catholiques d'un
département dans les yvelines
sarko est une vraie responsabilité parce
que les yvelines en deux mots c'est 180
prêtres en activité mais surtout 70000
personnes qui sont à la messe tous les
dimanches dans les yvelines
et après ça vous avez tous les enfants
du caté vous avez les scouts près que
les scouts dans les yvelines c'est plus
de dix mille jeunes
voyez donc dans les yvelines l'église
est très vivante le diocèse est gros il
est dynamique il est jeune on en sait
beaucoup de chance et ça nécessite
beaucoup d'investissements lévesque
étant responsable de tout ça il a
souhaité être écoulé les évêques doivent
se choisir une deviez vous avez opté
pour un passage des actes des apôtres de
saint pierre il est passé en faisant le
bien pourquoi vous avez choisi cette
devise
parce que je crois que la bienveillance
dont il est question dans ma devise
épiscopale est un des enjeux essentiels
à la fois de la société française dans
laquelle on est et
un des services que l'église peut
apporter à la société aujourd'hui on
voit bien que la crise des gilet jaune
par exemple est la violence que suscite
une telle crise à quel point il ya
besoin aujourd'hui de d'apôtres de la
bienveillance c'est ce que j'espère être
et l'ordination épiscopale se déroulera
donc le 20 janvier en la cathédrale
saint-louis à versailles ça se passe
comment une ordination épiscopale
alors c'est une cérémonie assez solennel
qui rassemble les autres évêques de la
région parisienne
même un peu au-delà en france ceux qui
peuvent venir et c'est un peu comme pour
l'ordination d'un prêtre ou d'un diacre
c'est un sacrement qui permet à la
personne qui le reçoit d'entrer de
manière irréversible dans une espèce de
transformation intérieure définitive
dans sa nouvelle fonction depuis votre
nomination vous avez déjà quitté la
paroisse de montigné voisins ça va se
faire dans les prochains jours samassa
dans les prochains jours probablement
faire dès fin janvier avec un petit
pincement au coeur
j'imagine avec un gros bras sont au
coeur parce qu'on compare pas de 50 à
100 passe mon coeur c'est un endroit qui
est très attachant très dynamique très
jeune et donc heureusement ayant une
responsabilité pour tout le département
j'aurai l'occasion de repasser à saint
quentin mais c'est vrai que je quitte
avec avec regret cette ville et cette
communauté que j'aime beaucoup
il y avait notamment un projet de grande
envergure cette grande église qui doit
voir le jour prochainement sur sur ce
cette paroisse de montigny oiseaux oui
alors ça fait des années que le diocèse
souhaite construire une grande église de
800 places sur le terrain de la remise
et c'est vrai que là on y est on est sur
le point de déposer le permis on espère
que les travaux pourront commencer dans
les mois qui viennent et du coup ben
voila je passe la main au moment où les
choses vont commencer c'est la vie et le
nom de votre successeur sera connu à
prochainement dans les jours qui
viennent - merci monseigneur bruno
valentin d'être passé sur ce plateau je
rappelle que vous avez été nommé en
décembre évêque auxiliaire de versailles
que votre ordination épiscopale se
déroulera le 20 janvier en la cathédrale
saint-louis de versailles merci d'être
là c'est sur ces bateaux il était une
fois saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'intitulé d'une conférence donnée hier
au vélodrome nationale à montigny le
bretonneux organisé par le club
d'affaires happy hour business club ce
rendez vous était animée par robert
cadalbert l'ancien conseiller régional
et président socialiste de
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise a
livré quelques souvenirs et anecdotes
vécues à lorsqu'il officiait au sein de
collectivités des histoires sur
l'arrivée du technocentre renault à
guyancourt sur le projet pour accueillir
la ryder cup est aussi sur l' aventure
olympique de saint quentin en yvelines
robert calda berkane d'albert pardon on
raconte d'ailleurs une anecdote sur la
construction du vélodrome nationale
c'est au micro de nicolas d'andré c'est
une longue histoire
par exemple j'ai eu l'opposition pour la
construction du vélodrome
parce que l'association qui voulait la
bicyclette mais pas le vélo et la
dernière ce qui nous a coûté un peu
d'argent a donc tous les contribuables
c'est le fait que tous les recours était
possible nous avaient trouvé des tritons
crêtés sur l'emplacement du vélodrome et
qu' il a fallu une faire une sorte de
deux pouponnières de triton crêté qui
sont à l'entrée personne ne sait à
l'entrée du vélodrome
j'avais une petite barrière dans une
mare et c'est effectivement une
pouponnière pour triton crêté robert
cadalbert ancien élu aussi de guyancourt
justement meyer la mère marie christine
le tarnec a présenté ses voeux à la
population la cérémonie s'est déroulée
au sein du pavillon waldeck-rousseau
bonsoir au rayon que s'est-il dit
pendant la soirée
alors juste avant le discours de madame
le maire l'aiguillon courtoise et
guyancourt tongs pu assister à plusieurs
performances artistiques du dessin avec
du sable de la danse ou encore du rap
après avoir rappelé appelée sur scène
ses conseillers municipaux et plusieurs
élus de saint quentin en yvelines
1 marie christine le tarnec a
particulièrement orienté ses voeux sur
le vivre ensemble et le partage vous
propose de l'écouter
je pense qu'une ville elle ne peut
fonctionner que si un certain équilibre
et cet équilibre se fait effectivement
dans tous les domaines et ensemble cette
ville on la partage
on la partage on partage des espaces
communs on partage des esquives mans on
partage des valeurs et c'est que ça qui
fait que lui en cours est une ville où
on aime bien et vivre on le sait les
voeux c'est l'occasion de faire le point
sur 2018 aussi annoncé les grands temps
forts de 2010 9 est ce qu'il ya eu
quelques annonces durant cette cérémonie
alors oui la taxe d'habitation par
exemple n'augmentera pas en 2019
il y aura également une inauguration en
havre
d'un relais d'assistantes maternelles ou
encore la livraison à la fin de l'année
d'une résidence intergénérationnelle
quartiers ont du rotois et puis vous
l'avez certainement vu sur ses
précédentes images trois personnes ont
reçu la médaille de la ville de
billancourt c'est aussi ça rend la
cérémonie des voeux de début d'année
dont trois personnes dont paul yen à
hernych qui est directeur du golf
national merci aurélie pour ce point un
prochain tour d'horizon sur les voeux de
l'agglomération avec la ville de plaisir
ça sera demain dans ce journal
retour en 2018 à présent pour se
rappeler des faits qui ont marqué les
yvelines l'an passé ce soir direction la
période de juillet à septembre avec des
victoires et grands événements sportifs
souvenez-vous avec marylène yapi chine
le mois de juillet est marqué par un
événement qui a mis en joie toute la
france la victoire des bleus en coupe du
monde de football 6000 supporters se
sont rendus au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines pour garder
son équipe décrocher sa 2e et 3e
or autour des champions les jeunes de
l'étoile sportive de trappes ont été
conviés à l'elysée
des souvenirs un ex b/j pas l'élève
provost autres scènes de joie dans les
lycées les résultats du baccalauréat les
épines deux minutes classement de
l'académie de versailles avec un taux de
réussite les 93% le monde politique
avait les yeux tournés sur versailles le
9 juillet pour le deuxième discours du
président de la république
emmanuel macron face au congrès du
parlement dernier conseil municipal
difficile à coignières pour son maire
jean-pierre sevestre qui se termine par
une mise en demeure à son encontre après
l'été le maire élu en 2015 a finalement
présenté sa démission en septembre
pour moi c'est la meilleure solution
parce que je considère qu'il convient
maintenant de donner la parole aux
poignets rien pour leur permettre de
peut même de choisir l'avenir de leur
ville serait non
après une préparation d'élections peut
appliquer un perdant donc plus tard
changement importante sur les routes au
1er juillet le passage à 80 km heure
pour les départementale les gendarmes et
bin-houin on fait de la prévention pour
sensibiliser les automobilistes à
villepreux ont fêté l'arrivée de l'été
en couleurs avec la première édition de
la colonne au parc du trial
avant de vous toutes les couleurs sur le
soleil du mois d'août s'est assombri
attrape par une attaque au couteau un
homme de 36 ans poignardé trois
personnes les deux premières sa mère et
sa soeur sont mortes
le tueur a été abattu par la police une
enquête est toujours en cours
le mois de septembre a fait sa rentrée
de nombreuses personnalités politiques
sont passés par les yvelines la ministre
du travail mme muriel pénicaud est venu
inaugurer le campus de l'automobile et
des mobilités a depuis en cours
jean michel blanquer ministre de
l'éducation a visité une école de poissy
faisant partie du dispositif de
dédoublement des classes
le ministre des comptes publics gérald
darmanin lui est venu parler budget face
aux événements à marly le roi enfin
marine le pen présidente du
rassemblement national a choisi mantes
la ville pour faire sa rentrée régional
chez nos élus locaux le maire de vie pro
stéphane mirambeau rend public son
adhésion à la république en marche le
soutenir
emmanuel macron dans ses réformes je
peux le pays mérite vraiment et a besoin
d'être réformé le week-end des 15 et 16
septembre se dérouler les journées
européennes du patrimoine à saint
quentin en yvelines une trentaine de
lieux ont ouvert leurs portes au public
était associé dès le départ de la
création de la ville nouvelle sur saint
quentin en yvelines la veille avait lieu
le loto du patrimoine ainsi turinois
étaient concernés la villa viardot à
bougival
les gains de cette loterie exceptionnels
ont permis la remise d'un chèque de 500
mille euros pour sa rénovation
le président de la république emmanuel
macron ferrand de lui même sur place
pour la portée des moments insolites
avec nos amis les bêtes le zoo safari de
thoiry proposer son tout premier 10 km
au milieu des animaux de la savane un
événement succès qui devrait revoir le
jour en 2010 neuf fois ci s'est illustré
comme la ville du fou de ce mois de
septembre le psg a dévoilé son futur
centre d'entraînement de 74 hectares
les travaux doivent débuter durant l'été
2010 9 et le champion du monde 2018
blaise matuidi est venu inaugurer un
mini stade tout neuf a su nous ici si tu
content le blog hors murs ce jour mais
l'événement sportif du mois de septembre
et sur un tout autre terrain la ryder
cup 2018 a jeté un coup de projecteur
sur saint quentin en yvelines
60000 spectateurs par jour se sont
rendus au golf national pour assister au
sacre de la team europe
une semaine fantastique une grande
expérience pour tous les spectateurs
et puis voilà en fussent à la fin c'est
l'europe qui gagne donc c'est génial
peut pas s'entraîner bah oui oui ça
c'est c'est c'est la fin d'une histoire
mais mais c'est merveilleux on espère
encore de grands événements cette année
sur le territoire elle et veut se
souhaite tout le mois de janvier on peut
pourquoi pas continuer aussi à célébrer
noël bonsoir francine charloton on se
marre d'être la chargée de communication
de l'association réveille toi une
association qui est basé à elancourt
alors elle organise ce samedi à sa fête
de noël c'est à l'agora à de 12h30 à
18h30 c'est le centre social municipal
d'elancourt déjà rêver le toit rappelons
ce qu'est cette association ça fait deux
ans qu'elle existe
elle vient en aide aux familles
monoparentales c'est cela oui donc c'est
une association créée depuis deux ans
par trois mamans dont moi monoparentales
qui nous sommes retrouvés dans des
difficultés nous entraider et on s'est
posé la question de ce qu'on pouvait
faire pour d'autres personnes dans la
même situation situation de rupture
séparation et de monoparentalité
éventuellement et du coup on a
effectivement émis l'idée de monter une
association pour réunir les parents
concernés et pour créer notamment un
espace de retrouvailles de répit des
coûte un espace de libération de la
parole de façon à ce qu'on puisse aussi
trouver des solutions ensemble
quand on élève son enfant seul pourquoi
il faut avoir aussi cet accompagnement
être aider au quotidien
oui il faut surtout ne pas rester isolé
parce que c'est le premier ennemi de la
famille monoparentale parce qu'on perd
on perd des contacts on perd des amis on
perd une partie de sa vie
s'isole on perd l'estimé de soi et ça
peut impacter différents niveaux de
notre vie notamment la vie familiale
aviv professionnelle etc
et l'idée c'est de rester une famille
normale en étant dans cette situation là
en tout cas parce que c'est une
situation qu'on espère toujours
transitoire deux ans qu'elle existe donc
cette association nombreuses actions qui
sont organisées notamment la formule
régulière du café débat c'est
quel bilan vous fait oui sûr c'est sur
ces deux ans sur les différentes actions
organisées alors les cafés débats c'est
notre action phare à un café débat par
mois avec des thématiques qu'on voit
avec de plus en plus avec les adhérents
sur leurs problématiques sur leurs
difficultés leur demande avec des
intervenants extérieurs donc de plus en
plus de personnes adhèrent à ce format
est vielle justement à ces cafés débats
pour déjà se retrouver entre eux de
trouver des solutions à leurs
questionnements et puis aussi gérer
leurs enfants parce qu'on accueille les
enfants lors de ces cafés débats pour
permettre aux parents d'être là avec
nous mais ça peut être quel type de
thématique par exemple ces thématiques
ça peut être géré ça c'est pas là de sa
séparation
comment élever son enfant comment gérer
la scolarité de son enfant
comment
être à l'écouté voilà enfin différentes
thématiques qui permettent autant aux
parents qu'aux enfants de se retrouver
et puis de mieux se gérer ensemble mais
d'autres actions aussi organisé par
votre association notamment cette fête
de noël ce samedi à l'agora pourquoi
proposer ce rendez vous alors parce
qu'on aurait pu le faire en décembre
mais on n'a pas eu la possibilité et on
s'était dit que c'était bien de clôturer
l'année de démarrer l'année avec un
climat convivial
donc on a mis en place cette fête de
noël avec tous les adhérents
donc comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
réveille toi c'est une association créée
par les parents solos pour des parents
solos et qui est gérée par des parents
solos et autres parce qu'on n'a pas que
des parents solo chez nous il faut le
savoir
donc tout le monde participe tout le
monde amène son idée tout le monde amène
sa pierre à l'édifice et ça fait une
ambiance conviviale et c'est vrai que
les gens sont contents de se retrouver
et là notamment sur cette fête de noël
qu'on organise depuis près de deux mois
où différentes activités seront
proposées décoration de sapins de noël
décorations de décoration tout court
atelier maquillage atelier cuisine
atelier musical
voilà on et propose des choses variées
pour les enfants et pour les par
l'objectif c'est ce que ce soit
convivial c'est le maître mot c'est ça
et c'est ouvertement à vos adhérents
c'est alors la fête de noël elle va se
faire là des gens n'a pratiquement
clôturer les désinscriptions mais par
contre l'association est ouverte à toute
personne ne veut venir mensuellement
donc il faut nous contacter soit par
mail soit par d'autres sites facebook
notre site internet où notre compte
facebook le site internet qui s'affiche
actuellement en bas de l'écran nous
reste quelques secondes un peu plus
d'une minute même là pour parler de
l'année 2019 qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter et quels sont les projets pour
2019 alors de pouvoir refaire le projet
qu'on a fait en 2018 pour la première
fois avec une autre association de
pouvoir organiser des vacances on a
organisé des vacances l'année dernière
pendant une semaine au pouliguen avec
cette famille
2 révèle doigts et de l'association
second souffle qui est une association
qui est plus sur le handicap et cette
année on espère réitérer cette formule
avec plus de personnes pour partir une
semaine
ou peut être deux et ce avec le soutien
de nos sponsors on va dire de nous voilà
il ya la mairie à la cgt il ya parents
solos et compagnie et pas mal d'autres
que je n'oublie peut-être de cité mais
voilà donc on espère pouvoir mener à
bien ce projet de vacances pour offrir
un moment de répit aux parents et en
même temps au monde rencontre entre
parents et enfants pour mieux se gérer
toujours tous ensemble donc à leur
projet pour 2019 et sur les cafés des
bases qui a déjà des prochains
thématiques qui sont a lancé le 16
février nous aurons un café débat sur
comment gérer sa douleur après la
séparation avec la présentera un
écrivain il s'appelle la vie connaît de
saint cyr qui a notamment écrit les
accords toltèques au quotidien et le 16
mars c'est un café débat sur le logement
voilà merci l'idée la jeune française
charloton d'avoir été avec nous le
chargé de communication pour
l'association réveille toi et toutes ses
dates on y retrouve bien sûr sur votre
site internet ce qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran on reste à elancourt pour
refermer à ce journal avec notre petit
tour hebdomadaire à des salles de cinéma
saint-quentinoise focus sur le ciné 7
avec son directeur lui beaucamp c'est au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
cette semaine aussi les sept plein de
très bons films
d'habitude on des salaires mais cette
semaine une sortie nationale
et nous donc qui est une adaptation
d'une pièce de théâtre qui raconte la
jeunesse de cyrano de bergerac
c'est très très drôle savoureuse et ça
raconte vraiment l'histoire de
l'écriture de la pièce et cetera dans le
pré tout ceux qui s'intéressent à cyrano
de bergerac et ils sont nombreux
n'hésitez pas à venir découvrir ce film
dans nos salles et ensuite une petite
sélection de très bons films aussi que
vous proposons wild life avec jake
gyllenhaal qui est pas très joli film
la palme d'or du festival de cannes le
film chinois une affaire de famille en
vf et en vo je précise que nous
proposons aussi cette semaine
l'empereur de paris de jean françois
richet avec vincent cassel et amanda le
très joli film avec vincent lacoste qui
raconte l'histoire d'un jeune homme qui
vit sa vie jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient
confrontés à la mort de sa soeur et à
l'obligation de s'occuper de sa petite
nièce et je ne voulais pas finir sans
vous parler du phénomène actuel bohemian
rhapsody qu'il faut absolument venir
voir en salles nous l'avons toujours de
vous proposons en version originale et
version française
le film fait déjà fait quatre millions
d'entrées et j'ai appris hier soir en
écoutant la radio que la bande originale
du film cartonnait aussi dans les bacs
des disquaires et
quinn est en tête des ventes de disques
c'est qui est une très bonne nouvelle
c'est grâce au film donc venez voir
l'histoire de ce grand chanteur et
grands artistes qui étaient freddie
mercury dans nos salles cette semaine
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal le
replay sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile dans un instant le
retour du 7-8 débat le thème pour cette
première émission de l'année
perturbateurs endocriniens comment les
éviter
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]